greetings [__] it's monday the
23rd
of november it's gobble gobble week but
let's start up
correctly all right uncle joey's joint
is brought to you by
united harvest you're like joey what the
[__] is your
united harvest i'd love to welcome these
guys to this show with open arms
and a full stomach there are lots of
other companies that will sell you meet
the box
it never looks like the pictures and it
tastes like the cardboard they set it in
these guys united harvest sent me a box
of meats
that blew my mind pork belly ribs
biscuits chop sausages lamb
and a rib by that my wife cooked up on
thursday night that was [__]
delicious
i wanted to marry all over again the
meat is fresh
it's packed it's sealed our freezer is
packed for the winter
or whatever the hell they're gonna show
up with united harvest is the new
virtual farmers market get the best that
american ranchers have to offer
without leaving your house here's what i
want you to do
go to unitedharvest.com that's
united harvest
and pressing code church to get 20 off
the website with your order of 50
or more that's unitedharvest.com
use promo code joey check let me tell
you something the ribs
look [__] tremendous the brisket
looks [__] tremendous
so i'm telling you right now stay out of
the grocery store
nobody wants to [__] be walking
around with a headache on thanksgiving
if you value quality flavor and
convenience
check out unitedharvest.com and be sure
the promo code joey to save you 20 off
your first order let me tell you
something that rib eye steak was
delicious guys so
go to united harvest right now press in
promo code joey
the church is also brought to you by
manscaped right here
the best in man's grooming from your nut
sack to your nose
they got you [__] covered and right
now the holidays are almost here
and they're the most want number one
wanted gift right now
is manscape you gotta trim that [__]
tree pole
if you wanted to tickle your [__] nut
sack manscape is the perfect gift
dads brothers uncles everybody has been
sitting on their asses
for months growing [__] roots and
malukia sticks
that gets eliminated today with man
escape
it also has a weed whack a nose and ear
trimmer
with 9 000 rpm motor
and a blade that moves 360 degrees
back and forth check this [__]
out right there
tremendous nice and quiet you could do
it in the closet
you could do it on the on the plane
before the covet test tonight
when you land in new york you can do
whatever the hell you want
that's manscape so do yourself a favor
right now
go over to manscape.com and get free
shipping
20 off and free shipping at
mansgame.com use code joey that's 20
percent off with free shipping
at manscape.com use code
joey j-o-e-y and trust me
your balls will thank you and your nose
will thank you sniffing all those
farts they go right into your hair
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
lion the best as a matter of fact
the best is starting up a sale today
november 23rd
go to cbd lion they just added a dark
chocolate
and a milk chocolate that is [__]
tremendous
we still got the the gummy bears we
still got the roll-on
we still got the bad balls we got it all
for you
over there at cbdline.com go over there
and read the third
party uh third party test results
and you'll see why cbd lion is not
[__] around and again another great
gift for the holidays somebody some cbd
tape
there you go they keep bitching at you
oh i can't walk up the stairs
get them some cbd tape for their knees
go to cbdline right now.com
and press in joey or church and get 20
off delivered right to your
[__] crib
that cbd lion
candles are lit [__] let's get
this [__] party started
hey how you doing come on
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's monday the 23rd
of november another episode of uncle
joey's joint
i'm here i'm queer what's happening how
was your weekend
my weekend was the same as every other
weekend
no [__] comedy i guess they're
starting to close back
[__] backed up down whatever the [__] up
down all around they're just starting to
close [__] up
and there's nothing you can do i mean uh
what turned into three weeks
four weeks has now been eight [__]
months and uh
it's a holiday season to come so
everybody's a little moon and
gloom right now me i feel okay what are
you gonna [__] do
uh they could take away your livelihood
they could take away this they could
take away that
but they can't take away who the [__]
you are [__]
especially on a monday [__] morning
here this year you know
thanksgiving is when you sit around and
you give thanks for what you have
your family and they're telling you you
can only get together with two families
you can't sing you can't talk loud you
can't yell
only two hours so expect
uh whatever the [__] to happen after
this i mean
it sounds a little like communist cuba
only two families could come over
you could talk for [__] two hours but
you do the best you can
you know if you gotta wear a [__]
mask i wouldn't go
somewhere where there's a lot of [__]
people this weekend i'm keeping my [__]
low i don't i don't ever go out on black
friday shop
but if black friday don't spoke of audio
situations
i don't know what then you see every
year people fighting and arguing and
[__]
ripping their masks off and [__] this
year it's gonna be tremendous black
friday i don't know what the [__]
they're doing
i don't know if they're just gonna do
mail only or amazon or whatever
but it makes no [__] difference to me
it's thanksgiving week man
and uh you know usually these weeks you
sit around thanksgiving
a couple weeks uh the holidays and you
reflect on the year that passed
and you give thanks for what's in front
of you well you know what man
as much as you people are [__] having
a hard time and whatnot
there's still thanksgiving you helped
you got the people
around you i'm sure all these aren't
going to [__] stick to the [__]
curfew
of just sit there by yourself and
isolate whatever
solitary uh whatever
and just have thanksgiving by yourself
i've done enough of those
you know and like i said i'm gonna
[__] do thanksgiving
i'm gonna go down and see my brother
first and see his family
i'm gonna mask up because they got some
old people down there
and now from i'm going to some dear
friend's house
i'm going to spend thanksgiving with
them they're only going to have like
seven or eight people over the [__]
house
and then from there i'm gonna catch
dessert over another buddy of mine's
house
on the way back and by that time the
bulk of his family will have gone
he's gonna have some windows open and
with any luck
we got some nice weather if we get some
nice [__] weather
then it'll be nice and easy everybody
opens the door you could fart
you could smell farts and breathe and
everybody's all right can you imagine i
said
as it is already now i'm having a
[__] hard time with like restaurants
sitting inside but
the numbers are okay down here in this
county
they're a little higher up in uh up
northern new jersey
new york city shut down philadelphia
shut down
the club shut down my heart goes out to
them my hunt goes out to wendy curtis
out in denver
they shut her down on friday two of the
best clubs in the [__] country
and her restaurant so and this is why i
didn't want to make dates
i didn't want to get all excited make
dates and start thinking that things
were going to clear up because i had a
funny feeling they weren't
i mean college kids are going to be
coming back home
you're going to have gatherings listen
every morning you wake up and you go to
yourself ah today they won't lock us
down
we have another week another two you
know they're rolling back restrictions
in california
even though they they caught that
governor newsom having dinner with 15
[__] people and that's the thing i
don't understand that listen man
you lead by example you lead by [__]
example you know i'm not a governor i'm
not a senator
i ain't [__] you know what i'm saying
but even i try to walk the walk
if i'm in here talking to talk that's
the least i can [__] do
i tell you guys i take care of myself i
drink water i [__]
work out you know i'm looking at
different options to do because it's
[__]
boring in the daytime you just can't
write [__] jokes all day
they've taken away our jokes outlet i
mean i've got my uncle vinnie's i did
great last week at uncle vinnie's if you
came to the show
you had a great time last week for the
first time
in nine months i had a beginning a
middle and a [__] ending
thank god thank [__] god that meant
the world to me
but uh you know that 38 people they're
running with 38 capacity
so uh some of us have nothing
and some of us have a little something
to work with
just to keep the i could go down there
every night listen i go out every night
but there's a lot of things at stake
there's my health and the other thing is
there's a lot of other comics that need
work too
it's not just me there's a ton of comics
in this area
that could use some work and you know
you got a distressed factory
you got uncle vinnie's comedy club down
in point pleasant
you got the gold you of comedy the dojo
of comedy you got sam tripley's place
you got bananas you got some places in
jersey
but it's like a [__] third to the
comedians that they have
so everybody needs to make a little
[__] money you know i take wednesday
nights i don't take comics
big nights which is the weekends and uh
that's what that's what my [__] plan
is that's why i didn't want to book up
december
people offered me new years we don't
know what the [__] we're gonna do
and we don't know where the [__] we're
gonna be so why book something
now i got it hanging out over my head so
next
august in the middle of everything else
once everything clears up
i got to stop what i'm doing and go make
up a date from [__] two years ago
that's not what i want to [__] do
i want to start this slate off fresh
when we know exactly
go out and be comfortable in comedy
clubs i doubt it's going to be [__]
theaters
just go to [__] comedy clubs and
start from there
i don't care if 100 people are going to
come out i don't see a lot of people
running out
you know the vaccines are hitting the
[__] shelves here
any day now you got the one that's 28
days
that's like putting icicles in your
[__] blood then you got the other one
that's just [__]
uh i don't know i don't pay attention to
this stuff
all i'm trying to do is live for today
and how we're gonna make it happen today
you know
right now is the time when people call
you up and they go hey what are you
doing next saturday
i don't [__] know we don't [__]
know because we don't know where the
[__] we're gonna
be at right now so philly's surrounded
right now and new york is [__] closed
we're right in the middle of that am i
not right we're right there we're right
in the [__] middle so
obviously we're next and the sad thing
is like listen
i don't give a [__] about me you know
you know mike what do you do with your
time not much you watch your kids are
growing that's it
that's all we're doing right now so for
me it's time closing the schools again
like europe closed locked down but let
the schools open
this school that my daughter goes to
hasn't had a burp and the other one in
town hasn't had a burp not even a
[__] mishap
not even a teacher not even a [__]
email
so that's the only thing i'm worried
about they close up the kids once you
close up the [__] kids
and the schools over the holidays we're
gonna have a lot of [__] problems
because there's really nowhere to go
it's not like at least in california
you could take them for a [__] bike
ride it's it's
60 70 degrees here it's already starting
to get nip in the [__]
hair jack there ain't much to go and you
know me guys
every day i try to toughen it up it's
colder it's colder
i go for my little [__] walks you
know but after a couple minutes
it's [__] cold out there i got the
long underwear on order
i got the long t-shirts on order it's
gonna get cold for a chubby dude and
trust me i haven't been in the [__]
winter
i haven't been to colorado winter since
84 when i was homeless
i did 12 i did new jersey winter when i
was homeless
i did 12 colorado winters but you could
do those with a [__] hooded
sweatshirt on
those aren't that bad they only got
about two weeks of really really
really really intense cold [__]
weather in colorado
the rest of the year is you know yeah
it's 32 for three days but then it goes
up to [__] 70 for four days
and everything melts it's hard to take a
cap you know
if you're a [__] weatherman in
colorado that's a tough [__]
[__] right there jack that's a tough
[__]
i know you guys there were some ufc
fights this weekend
i did not even watch them i don't have a
[__] clue what's going on
anymore in the ufc that is crazy that
somebody called me up saturday night and
they're like hey
are you watching the fights and i'm like
what [__] fights
i didn't know there was a fight on the
card i didn't know when they told me who
was fighting i had no idea who the [__]
they were
so i'd love to talk about the ufc with
you [__] but
i don't know dick i know the jets are
0-9
they suck dick i know cam newton is
trying his best up there in new england
new england's [__] dying i love you
guys with all my heart
you know i'm not here to goof on you but
we all knew was gonna be a tough [__]
season
now you gotta add covert to that
[__] new england's like
[__] we had dynasties up here for 20
years
we had white people throwing touchdowns
and [__]
that [__] all changed our boy [__]
our boys down in tampa bay nice and warm
he brought he brought his little buddy
gromkowski back
he's got antonio brown now who knows
what's gonna happen that's a shame
to see new england go from [__] that
powerhouse all those years
to just a regular [__] theme i've
been paying attention this year
why because i got nothing else to do and
for the first week on sundays now i'm
forced to watch football
so i go over to jimmy florentine's in
the afternoon
eat a slice of pizza and i watch some
[__] football with the guys when was
the last time i sat around
and watched football with the guys never
because i was always
too busy [__] landing and [__]
getting my [__] luggage ready and
throwing my laundry on the whole [__]
deal
but things have changed things have
changed you're sitting there at home
like joy
why is this happening to me this is
happening to everybody
and on top of the [__] [__] that's
going on and on top of the shutdowns
and on top of unemployment not asking
the phone you got just like people with
bad luck going around
that my heart goes out to them they
cannot catch a [__] break
i have a dear friend that cannot catch a
break right now
i have maybe four of them that they
cannot catch a break
whether it's looking for a new place to
move to
you know the job open and closed right
away
people are sick people are dying and man
it's like god's true test that tasted
that testing your [__] patience
and trust me i've been there a thousand
times in my life and i'm like
this is not happening and you know what
i'm talking about
money's not right your girlfriend's
giving you a hard time
your boss calls you sent out the wrong
stuff
and then you go out into your car to
start the car and you got a flat [__]
tie
it's getting to that point for people
where like they're like
you know well what the [__] is going on
i talked to a friend of mine something
happened to me got hit by the
he got blindsided and i go are you okay
and i mean he looks at it for what it is
he goes this is part of what's going on
right now
that's sad and we have to accept things
like that not only uh
things falling around around us people
are dying
you know it's not bad enough we don't
have a normal [__] life right now
but then the people around us are going
down
people around us have bad luck and you
know what i don't care how
i'm as optimistic as can be i'm tip top
and go every day i wake up with my dick
hard
ready to salute today but after two or
three of those phone calls
it just puts you in their position you
go what the [__] would i do if
if i was them right now whether they
have to find i mean i have a friend
who's looking for a pad now during the
holidays
you know how [__] hard that is to
find an apartment during the [__]
holidays and get settled and whatnot
you know i have another brother who lost
his [__] wife
it was his birthday friday when i go you
know when i talk to him friday he goes
this is the first time
in 37 years i've i've celebrated a
birthday without her i mean you know
people are having bad times and listen
you gotta toughen it up right now
because the times aren't going to get no
better they don't they're not going to
get better by themselves
it's not just going to miraculously
happen that the [__]
sun comes out and there you are [__]
jumping up and down
with your little fairies and boot pants
on and [__] it's not gonna happen that
way
it's gonna be a process but the most
important thing is you have to hold on
you have to look at it and just [__]
smile and go
this can't take me down this cannot take
me down
because it's just it's little things
it's little things but every day they
add up it's little things
your package didn't get there on time
you know
you got a flat tire the [__] light
bulb went out
the [__] computer thing went out like
little things and it starts
like i talked to a friend of mine his
hot water heater went out
the pipe went out in his house he said
see he was taking a shower and often
[__] started coming up through his
[__] tubes you know and and
you could sit there and be upset and
curse
and drink or whatever the [__] you do to
ease your attention
the best thing to do is just to sit
there and say this is part of the times
i mean it
happens here with me and i can't even
get upset about it you know
it's just part of what's going on right
now
how you respond to it is how bad it's
really gonna be
if you lose your mind over and go [__]
this is the end of the world and it is
going to be the [__] end of the world
but if you look at it and go up this is
just another day in the life
i got to come back a little [__]
stronger tomorrow
then you will come back a little
stronger tomorrow trust me man doug
i'm going through this [__] i went
through it with the comedy i went
through with the podcast and you know
what
it was like we had one day and here we
were taping
and one of my cats got stuck under the
[__] couch i mean you couldn't write
it
like we didn't have enough [__]
problems we did the podcast outside and
the microphone didn't [__] work
people were blaming poor mike it was my
fault i didn't [__] know it was my
first time out there
you know everything that can go wrong
can [__] go wrong but
what are you gonna do are you gonna get
depressed about it
roll up in a ball and [__] quit no
you pick up your balls you salute the
flag and you go we're gonna go for it
again
and again and again and again until i
get it [__] right and that's it
that's what being an american is
being an american is not going a [__]
outside diving
i voted with my little half a [__]
sticker on no
it's learning how to [__] get up
after you fall
it's learning how to get up after you
fall right now there's so many
balls going up in the air you know so
many [__] things going up in the air
but think about all those balls that are
getting juggled
what do they have to do with you nothing
all these balls are getting juggled in
the air black lives matter
this that whoever is talking about this
antifa
[__] the election how does it affect
your everyday life
is it gonna make your unemployment come
quicker is it going to make your kids
computer work faster on the [__] zoom
is it going no no so eliminate all that
[__]
eliminate all that [__] because that's
going to happen
whether you're involved whether you like
it whether you're not involved that's
all going to happen
all you can control is your [__]
house it's what what's in front of you
and your happiness listen man i'm having
a great time lately
i have a lot to be sad about and i have
a lot to be grateful about
what i have to be grateful about
outweighs what i have to be sad about
oh i can't do comedy well we'll do it
next [__] year that's it
you know i was telling somebody that
november is like a rough month for me
and they called me and they're like i
just want to check them with you
no i didn't mean it like that i meant it
that
it's just like you you think of things
how did they happen
i thought about my mom's life how did it
happen
how did she die and i moved forward i'm
not walking around johnny hill hum for
three days
i can't do nothing crawled up in a ball
looking for [__] attention woe is me
no this is just things that you look at
you look back at and you go how the [__]
did this happen
how the [__] did i end up there and how
the [__] did i end up here
you know i'm still in awe about the
[__] the no drugs and the addictions
and all that [__]
you know i'm kind of i'm a little
embarrassed about my sobriety
because my sobriety isn't like anybody
else's my sobriety works for me
that's the only person that's supposed
to work for it's not supposed to work
for johnny bananas
it's not supposed to work for johnny
luna there's a great podcast out there
called the dopey podcast i don't know if
you guys heard it
you know the guy was a stone cold
[__] junkie and he tells his stories
and whatever
now he's deep deep you know he's doing a
great podcast he helps a lot of people
and they tell great stories in the dopey
podcast you know he contacts me every
once in a while to do it
and there's something i don't want to do
it it's that my sobriety
is like everybody else's bright you know
i like to smoke my [__] pot
i don't drink but if i want to go go
over the [__] the place and have a
little sangria
from time to time i could have a sangria
do i get drunk
no i don't [__] get drunk anymore i'd
love to
be able to i drank on the [__] you
guys saw me have a drink
with uh the dream mateo podcast i just
wanted my refrigerator there was no
waters downstairs there was beers
so i took a stella i drank i didn't fall
all over the place
i didn't uh you know [__] my pants or
anything
i just don't do surprise like everybody
else
and with my sobriety i didn't want to do
[__]
coke or pills or ever put myself in that
position again
that was it i i took down what took me
down
reefer never took me down in fact reefer
makes me feel halfway [__] normal it
makes me feel like i'm doing something
at least a little
illegal to make me feel like i didn't
[__]
just switch governments and now i'm a
half a [__] full-time
i like smoking a little pot from here to
there it just makes me feel a little
dirty last night if you ate a few
edibles
it was sad they had nothing really on my
responsibility plate
so i ate them it's not like i used to be
in la eating edibles every day and
whatnot as a matter of fact
on patreon from now on we're gonna have
a little show we're gonna look at
different edibles
and how they affect you and uh what to
expect with from them
and you know whatever we're gonna start
that up pretty soon
just to let you know what the [__] we're
doing because i'm not eating a lot of
them anymore i'm not eating a lot of
anything
i'm just trying to get healthy i'm
trying to be a good husband
and i'm trying to get this podcast
together for you keep running this
patreon
so i don't get you people [__] hating
on me like you do but i don't give a
[__]
i'm going to keep saying what i got to
say whether you like it or
[__] not because what i'm talking
about is the truth here
uh keep keep an eye on your alcohol
consumption
keep an eye out on what you're doing
over the holidays right now i'm getting
it from a lot of people that
they're struggling with drugs or alcohol
and hey
it's a tough time to be a [__]
american right now
i spoke to my old drug dealer last week
just out of [__] you know
we call each other up i was telling a
story about
he used to have my old drug dealer had a
guy that lived in a stairway
you can't write this [__] so when you
walked into his house it was too leveled
but when you walked in there was stairs
and there was you know how every
stairway has little claws on there you
put your vacuum in there or whatever
he had a little black fellow that lived
in there his name was who dat i swear to
god
plus the guy was a [__] uh a
superhero
on hollywood boulevard so we'd be over
there [__] cop and coke
and all of a sudden the [__] hulk
would walk in you know
and the hulk is a big [__] this
guy was a skinny little black dude
and he lived under the stairs at the
house and we he would have a little
light in that he'd have his little
[__]
nintendo games and [__] and he'd come
out from time to time and challenge the
drug dealers
who were also african-american to
[__] you know like i'll play you with
nba4 like the game that i got
and they'd be like who that get back in
your [__] closet [__] before we
beat the [__] out of you
tremendous [__] you can't write this
stuff you know what i'm saying but
i was talking to my drug deal he was
telling me cocaine was up to 1800 an
ounce
and he can't get enough of it before
because the more he gets of it
the [__] more he moves of it it's
it's hysterical
so people out there snorting with
[__] three hands
thank god i'm not one of those people i
still got it down to my marijuana
and i'm very [__] happy with it but
what i was saying is
i don't do so brightly like anybody else
like i i just
i believe in the principles of uh aaa
a.a has worked for a lot of great
friends of mine that are friends of the
program
you know they're friends with john
they're [__] great with you you like
that who that
you know i gotta throw something in here
for you [__] it's not
all about boo-hoos and he's i gotta
throw a little story in there for you
sometime
oh it was hysterical here he'd just open
up the closet and come out with half a
hulk beautiful mine
so you have the big thick pants and the
top he looked like an x-ray like jesus
before he got stabbed
you're the hulk you're not supposed to
be [__] skinny
but what are you gonna do people things
are bad all over you i'm saying
all i'm trying to tell you is that this
week
be careful with the booze be careful
with the alcohol
new year's is coming uh you know
like i tell people to be able to i'll
start
doing drugs on the 31st listen
if you start now it'll be a lot better
for you if you start tomorrow
whatever journey you're going to start
in july on december 31st
you could start it today let's go wait
until december 31st for
everyone i'm not going to do that in the
cemetery listen people are gonna put
cookies up
i just can't eat 50 cookies you know
what i'm saying i could eat one
the first part of the joint there you go
the garlic is working i almost [__]
slipped out and went that way over my
head
but who gives a frenchman's [__] that's
why we're here we're doing what we're
doing [__] on the daily you know
what i'm saying he just farted on his
back
farts all the time it comes out of his
neck to poor bastard
i don't know what lee's doing he's up
there in boston he's been hiding lately
he's getting high with his mom he took
two edibles i told him
he's in training for us to do the zoom
he's gonna take [__]
two edibles five days in a row and then
we'll put him on the [__]
joint and he's gonna eat three the day
of
that's the only way they want to see him
we don't even show his head up there on
[__] you have nobody seen lee nobody has
seen lee
there are no [__] pictures of lee
nobody not even fba surveillance so
fbi surveillance that's always when
we're waiting to look for that one but i
don't know what the [__] going on with
them
but what i do know is uh we got a guest
today on the podcast we did a little
zoom with them
i'm trying to mix the podcast up for you
i don't want to be on here for an hour
like a [__] kavone
and try to tell you what i'm trying i
ain't trying to tell you nothing
all i'm trying to do is talk to you
[__] and make your mondays a
little bit better that's it
i'm not here to change nothing i'm not
here to [__] tell you that
uh you know all i'm here to do
is to wish you a great [__] monday
bring you a little bit of entertainment
a little clarity to your [__] world
and just know that it's [__]
thanksgiving [__]
it's our [__] week um
the guy i'm bringing on the podcast is a
friend
you know uh it started out by me being a
fan of his work
i saw i saw him in a couple of movies
and then i saw him as a young kid
on law and order and then one night i
was brought
watching bronx tale and i figured out
that it was this kid so i don't know
law and order was his first performance
or bronx tale was his first performance
and it just happened to be bronx tale so
he's been around for a long [__] time
and he just did a great job playing uh
fat tony salerno
and the irishman with de niro and pacino
i love the kid he's got a ton of respect
from me
he built the [__] uh a fort that i
saw
that i was just blown away and i reached
out to him and uh
he opened up his heart to me and spoke
to me and i
i see that he goes to other comedy shows
and whatnot
so i want to get him on the joint and
talk to him a little bit on a monday
morning
and that's what we did so now without
further ado
joint [__] mr dominic
lombardosi
i hope you enjoy it and i'll see you
[__]
wednesday pre-fucking thanksgiving
[__] stay black
dominic lombardoza here guys a [__]
acting savage how are you
good good thanks for having me joey i
appreciate it all you need is dean
martin there with the fire
going that's it that's it that's it how
are you
what was this line don't drink and drive
you might spill your drink
yeah dean martin was the [__]
all those guys would be in trouble now
for me too and people oh my god i'm
surprised they're having meat dude frank
sinatra
well let's speak of that um even
even like from a comedic standpoint
right i mean you you couldn't do comedy
that were in the seven you couldn't do
that in the colleges today
right i mean no no the caller even uh
the the cleanest cleanest guy in comedy
seinfeld
had was starting to have a problem with
colleges
he says there was being two pc wow
and that's that's jerry seinfeld you
know
yeah but if there's one
if there's one area where that has to go
out the window
it has to be in comedy it
i can understand i can understand a lot
of different places but
when it comes to comedy i mean comedians
they need
they they need that leash you know what
i mean
that's why you need a leash and you need
freedom at the same time
at the same time exactly at the same
time there's
there's a thin line you know that we
could use
it's part that you're classless or
whatever but
if you're talking what's in your heart
it comes out authentically
right and people know where you're
coming from you know
yeah uh there's a thousand million ways
to say something
it could sound bad or it could sound
good
i think the purity in your heart is what
makes it sound
like it's it's just another day at the
park
without a doubt but yeah yeah usually
good comedians and you
you know i love comedians man i i uh
a few of them are my friends and uh
i've always thought when when it comes
to comedians
nobody has it harder maybe writers do
uh people that uh you know uh see things
from inception
and create something and and maybe it's
because i'm an actor
i come i have a completely different
point of view
but when i talk to my comedian friends
or i see them work
i can never do that i can never do i i
mean i've been listening to you for a
very very long time
uh when you started with rogan and all
that stuff
and i i loved you guys together um
but yeah let me just go to the club
today and be trying new material
that that's that would freak me the [__]
out
i could see you know they did you know
they always do that survey
and they said what are people scared of
the most dying
and speaking in public yeah you know
public speaking is very very hard to do
and i don't think you know you know when
you do stand up
somebody comes up to you and says
dominic you're a funny guy
try stand up and you put in the back
burner you watch a couple tapes
when you go up there that high
you know that it's for theaters it would
be doing
live comedy in the theater live theater
right
like not you know sometimes you tape a
tv show
half of it is on segments on tape then
friday they come in
and they do the live stuff yeah you know
there's some rush you get from an
audience
oh absolutely i i had a little bit of a
taste of that
i did um i did a sitcom
uh we were doing the pilot and it was a
multi-cam it was
and and we would rehearse and then we
would uh
it would be in front of a live audience
kind of thing and i had my taste of that
and i i can't tell i wish the show i
wish it would have got picked up and
i would have had a few episodes to do
that
but um to make a long story short
it was a great feeling landing that joke
hearing the crowd laugh then resuming
it is i i i and
i hear it from theater actors too it's a
different type of rush it's musicians
they get the same thing when you have a
lot
a live crowd it's a whole other ball
game
like i never saw stand up live
i listened to richard pryor albums i
listened to lenny bruce albums
it all hit me when i went to see a show
by the name of beatlemania
i don't know if you remember that show
you were a kid with that chat
i've heard of it though yeah it ran in
broadway for a long time
and i remember leaving there thinking to
myself
like i i you know i i didn't know music
i was just a young kid it was a school
trip
but when i left that theater i kept
wondering about
how they felt up there how they felt
being up there
that always struck a chord with me and
in the back of my mind i just put it
deep deep deep that
someday i'm going to have to try that
right i don't know if it's going to be
with a guitar
i don't know if it's going to be by
myself you know i didn't know about
improv then i knew about nothing
right but i always knew i wanted to try
that
well that's yours i joined the band yeah
i joined the band the band broke up
in the sixth grade and uh i just knew
being a musician took a lot of work you
know like it
it took a lot of commitment so i bowed
out on the
on the musician stuff and then years
later
yeah it's a different different
discipline all together
it's funny i talked to a guy now that's
70 years old
he's been in three of the biggest bands
in the world
at one time or another and when i call
him sometimes
he still practices four hours a day
four hours a day he practices that's
that's just
that's to let you know and he's made it
three times over white snake
ozzy's band and somebody else's band
you know so for me to get that that and
he's 70 something years old
which is even more inspiring passion
passion too
with passion yeah you know if people
always want to know
they don't want to get into acting
because there's no money they don't want
to get into comedy where there's no
money they don't want to get into music
because there's no money
there's got to be passion before there's
money or
it's the verse
all that stuff comes along with it but
what they don't realize
is the the tremendous amount of
sacrifice
they think automatically you know i hear
it a lot of times you know my daughter
wants to be an actor my son wants to be
an actor i'm like great you know
um they should take some lessons and i
tried to steer
i tried to give advice to what i wish
i was told because i liked you joey i
took a long road with a lot of twists
and turns
you know and um i kind of
related to do you remember this come on
i don't know if you remember this camera
you remember the apex
uh auto uh a trade school
commercial yes the ball then you learn a
tool the tool goes in the box
you remember that yeah same thing with
me
i felt like my my whole career was like
that i go you know
try something if it didn't work well now
i know not to do that and
well not to do this i had nobody kind of
coaching me
so i i could relate to that so when i
give advice i try to give the best
advice and the most
honest advice and sometimes the honest
advice
is not what they want to hear no no they
don't
the honest advice is hard work yeah and
commitment and you know blowing off
weddings
to do what you you know uh walking over
dominic i got to put
i got to put you on a play and it works
tuesday through sunday and you got two
matinees
you know you people can't do that
they're like well i have to go to this
person's wedding
you know it's just so many and i'm just
talking about the topical sacrifices
i'm not talking about sleeping in a room
with another man
when you're a grown man you know driving
all night in a bus
with grown men these are sad smelling
feet
and men farting these are sacrifices
that you put yourself through
that as a college educated person for
example would say i don't need this
like i don't need this [__] right it's a
journey you know and you have to
just put you have to put yourself
completely in
or this just isn't going to work for you
you know
i believe that i believe that's the
advice i give myself that i
i've seen over the years i took some
acting classes
i loved to audition dominic i hated
doing the work
i have great advice for that uh uh an
active buddy of mine his name is john
dolman
fantastic actor great character actor
um he he he was uh
i played with him on uh on the wire he
played the uh the commander
i believe it was rawls and
i would always and i i've worked with
him in the after that
and um we were just talking and he has a
great perspective on it he goes well i
just look at it this way
it's acting for free yep
it's acting for free so you just go you
you learn and
it's like you're going to work that day
and you're not getting paid
and he's right so now when i do an
audition i really get into it it's like
i feel like i'm going to work the next
day i put myself on tape
because i'm here in westchester and
let's be honest that's the way things
are being done now and uh
i have a great time with it i have a
really great time i have a great time
trying
i still even though i haven't worked
since february
i still look at monologues and i try to
remember i just try to keep the uh
you know the uh the tools sharp so to
speak
um but um
i always had that approach i hated
audition i always felt it was a tedious
process i didn't like the room
sometimes i always felt people had this
brief conceived notion about me
and uh and it would get in my [__]
head
and i was like you know scrap that
this is a job going to work and
and i just roll them out i love it
just uh it's like you're acting for free
it's the best advice i ever got
how old were you when you got into it
young yeah it was um i believe i think i
was 14
for a bronx tale um it was an open call
and i remember going in with a bunch of
kids because i'm from arthur avenue
i grew up on um 187th street and
prospect
that's a good neighborhood yeah long
time ago
yep and um
i've remember all the kids everybody was
going i mean i really didn't care about
it i
you know i wanted to be a ballplayer you
know you know all i cared about was
playing softball
baseball you name it and um
it went in for a read and i kept getting
called back and called back and then
i mean joe you had to see these lines
people were coming in from staten island
brooklyn queens manhattan
everywhere coming to the playhouse that
was on arthur avenue
and um and it just dwindled
and i wind up getting the part one day
of work
principal roll got gone in the union my
mom made me join the union
in case if it's something ever needed
god bless her you know
and uh and then it wasn't
a few years later where i got i did this
independent movie called kiss me guido
was which was like this underground hit
that paramount picked up and distributed
and that's how i got an agent
but then you know it was uh
casting calls going in and
it's just a grind man
i still remember you on the episode of
law and order oh wow
yeah with glenny briscoe a long time ago
stolen stereos or some
[__] i didn't even have an agent at that
time
like those gigs i didn't have they were
just
i guess they would have a list and they
would call people and i remember going
to
those auditions they were like cattle
calls 20 people
15 people you would have to wait like an
hour and a half
two hours um but uh
yeah all the new york shows
um and i always get you never were on
the sopranos
how was the sopranos movie
it was great it was it was something i
was looking forward to because i always
wanted to work with david chase
right comedically speaking you know
i hit my goals i got to work with harold
ramis
analyzed this too not the best movie in
the world
but for me i got to work with harold
ramus one of the greatest comedy minds
and we talked and he gave me some advice
and i ran with it
and with with it's so weird what you
take from different directors
you know uh there's a well-known comedy
director in hollywood
that does a lot of shows for cbs i've
worked three times with the guy i've
never gotten nothing from the guy
like there's no i didn't learn anything
with uh i think the most i learned from
was like uh sam raimi was very good
to work with uh when i did a movie for
david spade the director spoke to me for
a little while
even though it was a line he taught me
how to deliver it a different way
right and it was great and then
who did i did my party yeah and then the
longest yard adam lets you do whatever
you want to do
yeah god bless him when it came to me he
was like
just do whatever you want to do so i had
him and chris rock
feeding me lines off you know like
the camera was on me but they're feeding
me [__]
giggling you were very good in that film
thank you i you know i didn't know what
i was doing i had no idea
what i was doing i was just looking at
nick de toro and looking at
adam and looking at buffalo bill
blooming rich
the guy from buffalo does a bunch of
movies you know i looked at the real
actors in that movie
and i just tried to copycat him you know
burt reynolds
that's all i did that was my first
more than three days on a movie right
everything up to that was three days
four days
i would get the scene with the credits
rolling through it in the beginning
this was the first time i had leeway
and the only negative thing about that
movie was
that there was like two camps
there was the the uh
stevens camp siegel the guy who directed
it
right and there was the adam sandler
camp
so you didn't know who was really
talking to you
so i would get direction from the
director and then adam would tell me
something different
[Music]
so i would do three or four takes
and make it work you know but i didn't
know what i was doing
that first day or that second day and i
got tracy morgan to the left of me
i got chris rock for the life of me i
had everybody
so it was i learned a lot from adam
i learned a lot from the director but
i always felt i i love learning
i love learning something i like when a
director says do this
you know when you learn something from
it with david chase here's the funny
story
i went on there with mike comedy
[__]
and he shut it down the first day wow
why i mean he didn't shut it down one of
the guys on the set came over and he
goes
stick to your lines oh
so you couldn't you couldn't want you
couldn't really add lip too much
no ad-libbing which i'm not used to
you know it's always your line and then
i add something
and it works this was the first time
i was told this is how we do it and it's
a reason
and when i did the first day i was like
now i get why
he's david chase right and it was that
quick
like i went i went back to my room and i
started re-watching episodes
and now i understood how he worked why
he used his income
you're gonna cut joe i mean you're gonna
you're gonna you're gonna come across
that
the more the more you you wind up doing
television
more the more film you do you you're
going to come across that
there are there uh there are certain
writer directors
or writers that that you know it's
it's what they put on the page and
that's what they want and then
like i work with judd apatow over the
last summer
and it was like a shooting gallery of
lines
you know and it's uh try this so
try that and then i've been on other
things where it's it's
it's every punctuation
everything oh you gotta you know it's
it's it's
exactly what's on the page because
that's their vision and i understand
that and i learned to respect that
even in auditions i always want to put
whatever on the page
because out of respect to the writer
because i haven't talked to the writer i
you know you don't feel these people
have you know you haven't seen them you
haven't talked to them
so i i always
have to give the writer that respect
and then if they say well you know if
you could think of something like i work
when i did the irishman on scorsese
scorsese allowed that play
there's a whole scene uh that first
scene where i'm sitting down with
pesci and de niro and it's the first
meeting where they come and visit fat
tony
maybe those first three four five lines
that introduction that's me ad libbing
bronx tale was ad-libbing the whole
elephant the gun
the gun stopping the elephant driving
the truck
that's that was all ad-lib so
at first i i give them what they want
and then if there's
something but you're gonna find that
you're gonna find that everywhere
i don't get mad at them i respect
everybody of course i don't get mad at
them at all no
not at all and i've worked with people
that have said you know what
that's a better line than what i had use
it i have worked with people
all they have said your line is better
you know use it or use my line first
and then throw half of that line in yeah
so i have worked with people
but i always want to respect the writer
you know but i also
have to look for a window as a comic of
course maybe that he didn't see
okay so i want to add a flavor to it
with chase it was by the book but
i saw the fruit of his
labor yeah you know like i saw it so
then i was like
okay how was it shooting the irishman
it was uh it was it was great i mean you
know i was working with uh
i mean come on i mean i was working with
guys who i admired my whole
my my whole life you know it's not
there's nothing i didn't know about them
nothing i didn't know about their work
to me joe pesci was everything
he was everything he's everything he's
he's my
you know i love deniro i i love and i
i've worked with de niro on threes
on three different occasions and to be
perfectly
he started my career i think he also
helped facilitate me
uh being in the irishman because at
first i didn't understand why
they would hire someone my age to play
somebody so old when they were eight
when they were getting everybody that
was old and they were aging them down
so that being said being in the more
when it comes to joe pesci i always
admired him the most
because i can understand probably the
obstacles he had to go through
you know and and man when he's on scene
when he's doing a scene he's there
he's present and uh
he owns everything he every every scene
he's in he just owns it man and
and uh he delivers all the time so i'm
sitting there he was great in the
irishman
uh he's he's i think he was phenomenal
he's phenomenal in it
and uh especially to play a character
that's that stoic
that's that reserved compared to
all the other roles that he's done with
marty and bob
and you know and just the more loud the
boisterous guy
now he's more he's more late and man he
delivered
you know and um i loved working with him
i i loved it i could tell you look great
everything about that movie was great
i've watched that movie
really yeah because i would get i would
get there at three
three o'clock in the morning sometimes 2
30 in the morning
and um mike marino would would start
it would be like four or five hours in
in makeup and then when
everybody came it was blocking time so
basically when i was finishing
my makeup which i was in a completely
different trailer
uh they were coming to work and i know
ray romano stephen graham
i know these people and they're sitting
at my table we're doing the scene and i
remember going up to ray and uh
hey ray what's going on how are things
going and he's like hey how you doing
ray romano i'm like no ray it's me
where where are you like no one knew
and joe i never seen without my makeup
so who knows
but um it was a real joy um
just sitting opposite and watching these
guys work joey i mean
it's it's like they communicate
telepathically they hardly talk on set
and they just know maria just come and
say you know let's do this
you know whatever and uh and then
they just they did just a well-oiled
machine
that's the best i could explain it
it was uh i waited for that movie in
anticipation
and it delivered everything
everything i wanted from that movie i
got i thought it was a great film
i mean it's a difficult film yeah you
know and uh
it's based and i remember i remember
reading the book and i
did all my research on f as much as i
possibly could on fat tony
because there really wasn't much
it really wasn't much and um
[Music]
and if you read the book marty the movie
could not
be it had to be that long
to tell that type of story because if
you read the book you'll understand why
but uh i don't have a problem watching a
movie for three hours
as long as it's a good movie me too
if it's good i have absolutely no
problem no problem with it
and i'll be i watch on a plane so i
won't get disturbed
i watched the irish spin on the red eye
it came out on thanksgiving
whatever that wednesday yeah and i was
going to miami that night
so i just [__] downloaded on netflix
stayed up all night took some edibles
and just watched the irishman twice
until i got to miami i was blown the
[__] away it was great you know
that's crazy so congratulations you did
great on that
thank you now what have you been doing
since february beside cooking
building reading monoliths
um a lot of personal stuff that i think
uh
me and you uh i we we texted each other
about
uh that's been taking up a lot of my
time you know uh
stuff with my mom and um
and uh
i tried to offset that with um
i built the uh the treehouse i loved it
i loved it
uh i i did so much work i i
i did so much work because when i bought
when i bought my house i gutted the
whole house and i did everything
and um so i just continued to do that uh
you know
need the the flagstones in the front so
i would do the flagstones
uh i some trees needed to be cut down i
cut down the trees i split the wood
um this is the wood right here so
tremendous yeah so um i i
i've always liked getting my i guess you
know people paint
and i like to physically do stuff with
my hands
i guess that's my outlet you know but
other than that
that's really what i've been doing you
know trying to
stay safe uh because i got to be around
my mom
and uh but other than that
you know how's your mental
i'm good you look good you look great
you know you're smiling still boxing
so i saw that yeah so
um yeah it's hard you know i'm not gonna
lie
it's it's a long time i i i want to get
back to work
but um there's just you know i'm not the
only one
you know it's these are there are a lot
of us that there's just nothing out
there right now
you know so if it means for everybody to
be safe
and then that's what it's got to be
that's what i'm doing i'm just trying to
stay safe i know uh
past this time away i got a show tonight
i do 38 people
it's socially distance you know down at
uncle vinny's
um i don't really do much
you know i'm i'm i have high blood
pressure it's controlled
but i'm still a little scared of getting
the uh
you know we're all taking the d and the
zinc and now they're saying melatonin
helps
and all this [__] uh i worked out today
i've been going to the gym just like you
you know and that's all we could do
drink water and get good sleep
yeah i mean you go to an actual gym
or do you go yes yeah see i haven't i
haven't been to uh
like an actual gym the place where are
you boxing
i go to my my buddy uh ralph faselli has
a place called contenders up in omonk
where i box and we hit the mitts
but if i do with him it's just me and
him
outside outside or inside and
i i mean he has the machines he has the
fog machines he has the steam machine
it's the cl it's probably it's the
cleanest place on earth
it's um and it's just that's that's what
i do and if not i
i'll either do pull-ups or dips or
or push-ups um at home
splitting wood dragging wood and yeah
you know
a lot of like i i basically got the
rocky 5 workout going on
so you know i try to do it all i got the
seven year old
yeah you guys are always welcome you
guys are always welcome to come up
all right you have children uh my
girlfriend has a son
yeah that's what i hold the treehouse
for he said
that's what i saw i was saying i don't
know if he's got i don't know if he's
got kids in that
no that's a great dream house treehouse
oh look look
i'm gonna be perfectly honest when i
bought my house
i imagined everything when i was a
little kid
the things i wanted and the things i
never got
because it just didn't allow for it you
know i grew up in
a five five story tournament on prospect
avenue
uh my parents always worked
they always did the best for us you know
they came here in 1969
so they would like that last wave from
from italy and uh oh [__]
yeah so they you know in retrospect
that's not a long time
no it's not it's not and um
i was here longer than them yeah
i've been here since 66 yeah so
wow that's true what part of it they
come from police
says police uh police region
and um so i remember these things like
the pool
you know and and the tree house and the
swings
and you know the the yard the
the garden all that stuff so i said when
i get a house man i'm gonna do this and
then
my girlfriend uh josefina she has um
a son and he's like i wish i had a tree
house i said you know what
[__] it went to home depot got water
started stripping all the wood and i
just started building it
and i built it for fresh santino and he
built it for my my neighbor has two
daughters
who the sweetest things and when they
want to go in they go in when they want
to go in the pool they go in the pool
as long as they got their mother's
permission and their mother their
mother's around
that's fine you got the pool too yeah no
built in or above the ground i i built
it in
good for you man yeah so you put some
investment in there you added some
equity
yeah it's funny with me yeah i did all
the work
yeah that's phenomenal yeah that's just
great
with me when i moved to this area i saw
that all the kids
had [__] swings and that same
gymnastic [__]
and i'm like if i buy one i don't mind
buying one for her
but she's gonna use the swing two times
yeah and then they go to the park and
they use the swing two hours
so it's just gonna sit in the backyard
what the [__] can i put back there
and all of a sudden you put the tree
house up
and i'm like i went back there i started
looking at the trees started doing a
little measuring
i i showed them um i
i i i showed them and you know
i showed him your podcast and and i said
look
listen to this guy see look what he says
and um it was when you mentioned the uh
when you called it a fort he's like he's
talking he's talking about my tree house
that's my treehouse he's talking about
and uh yeah yeah
so you put a big smile on his face you
know you blew him i love those things
i love i'm an only child at the end of
the day
yeah yeah my tree house was the [__]
closet so i would go in the closet
yeah yeah
i remember boxing's out there second
floor when i was i was so lazy i didn't
want to throw my baseball glove i didn't
want to go upstairs to drop off my
baseball glove
i would just chuck it up on this on the
fire escape
[__] fire you know the deal you know
the deal was such a big part of our you
know i
when i came from cuba i went to new york
city and i lived on 205 what's 88th
street
uh okay i went to ps 166
for my first uh two years then my mother
always had the bar in jersey so i ended
up going to catholic school
it's funny i went to my buddy's house
before and his kids having problems with
times tables
and he goes did you have problems with
time stamp i go [__] no
i went to catholic school those nuns
beat that timetable into you
oh yeah well i mean when i i mean they
eased up when i went
when you were going to school oh the
early 70s they were [__] you up dawg
did you get did they have the paddle
they had the paddles
they had the pointer yep and their bare
hands
man i had we i had uh god uh god love
him uh
father john no brother john brother john
he was yeah he was a brother they were
the two
brother brother gilbert brother john so
uh
brother john he had these ears
that were like this right
so every time he would turn around and
right on the board they would go quack
quack
so for some reason he thought it was me
and he go
and he turned around he goes you and he
had like
man his his index finger was almost like
a piece of iron and he would he would
point that you hit you in the chest he
goes
you better simmer down one but dozie
before i knock you down
he got the grace i i never forget this
guy but he had the things like this
um but none of the paddle stuff
and i heard stories about the paddle
because i have cousins that are your age
and uh they they told me
even the ruler on the hands ruler on the
hand stick your hands out
yeah holding the books with your hands
out your arms out
yeah you know and you think about it now
and it toughened me up a little bit i
didn't like it
but it's who i am today you know i i
don't like hitting kids
i have a daughter that i'll never touch
just because
i don't believe it changes you you know
it doesn't didn't do anything for me by
hitting me
no i was still a [__] savage what are
your plans for the rest of the year what
are you thinking
um just what are you hearing i'm hearing
um
i'm hearing i think we're supposed to be
locked down again right
i think when biden takes office this
probably be
a more i think a mandate of uh of of of
a lockdown
um if that's what it takes to
stop the spread of this thing and and
and and
maybe try to go back to some normalcy
man
you know and i i don't know i don't have
the answer
you know but what i can do is only stay
safe
and hopefully there's a project that i
could join
where it's safe and go back to work
i know there's there's a few productions
that are going going on but they're
they're existing
shows and they're kind of like skeleton
crews
and um but i don't know
i don't really know much about other
than that
but there are some things that are going
on
i guess it's from state to state i guess
and um but i don't know i would like to
go back to work
they talked to me about something in
december december 6th through the 8th
in wilmington and i'm like it's too far
away
it's too far for me to decide we don't
know where we're going to be
i don't want to be in wilmington north
carolina three
for three days work yeah
you know i don't know if we're gonna
have to quarantine on the way back
i don't know if they're gonna put us in
the hotel i turned it down
because i just didn't even wanna travel
in december i don't know what's going to
be going on
you know three weeks ago they offered me
philadelphia and a week later they shot
22 people in two days there
so i don't want to say i don't want to
commit to a city
go into that city and there's a bunch of
violence going on
and i gotta fly in and out of that
[__] city so for me
i'd rather take the chance to stay home
my family
and uh i'll take the knock we won't eat
out as
much yeah that's i gotta tell you man
it's uh
it's scary what's going on you know it's
uh it's it's a
part of me just doesn't get it i i i i
would think everybody would just want to
just
[__] uh bunker down be safe but it's
between this whole election and
everything i mean even if you go on
twitter the first thing you go on
twitter man it's like people are
throwing arrows at each other
yeah it's not good it's not good it's
not healthy and
a lot of these people what they don't
realize they're doing is they're
instigating so much stuff
you know you i remember you know i
remember being a little kid being in the
schoolyard
you know and you always had that kid who
would who would
who would ralph [__] up but he'll be the
first one to leave the
the schoolyard yeah and there are a lot
of people like that on twitter and they
don't realize the damage that they're
causing
they're fueling that you know you you
you fuel things i i understand everybody
has a perspective i don't i don't care
if you're a republican i don't care if
you're democrat
i really don't give a [__] i don't give
a [__] i don't care
i really don't and uh
but i do care about instigating and
instigating violence
and scaring people that i do have a
problem with because
at the end of the day that's gonna
affect me if i'm going to the store
you know come on three months you know
it's uh
but i i i think you know people have
nothing else better to do but get on
twitter and and just start uh
instigating stuff dom the sad thing is
that they really don't have nothing else
to do
and it's not their fault it's not a
position they've been put in they're
frustrated they're waiting for an
unemployment check
they're angry you know that's why it's
like acting
i always look at the scene before my
scene
if i'm going to do something with
dominic i want to know where dominic is
coming from
from that scene and where i'm coming
from
you know it's like the scene before you
know so
these people are at home they're not
getting through the unemployment
which is a [__] shame people they're
not working
their kids are out of school and they're
in the [__] house
you know uh they're getting time to
think which is
never good right when you get time to
think
and then you go to social media to get a
few laughs
because for me that's what social media
is a few laughs and keep in touch with
some friends from high school
and you can't post nothing everybody's
got if you post something negative
they go at you and if you post something
positive they go at you
so there's really no winning right on
social media
you know right now there's an abundance
of people on social media
because like you said they really don't
have anything else
to do right so
i i try to put content out there that
you know
hey you know you like yeah i you know
things that i do
you know i tried yeah i don't go on
twitter
or instagram to try to sway people and
what what what they believe and stuff
like that it's just
it's not who i am you know but then
again i'm able to have
i just wish people would sit down with
other people and have
some sort of dialogue i think that would
really help
you know and uh but it's just
back and forth stuff man and uh i i i
really don't want any part of it and
um so that's basically what it is for me
it's just
doing stuff putting putting it out you
know building the
the treehouse or whether i do something
around the house those [__] meatballs
look good too
a couple weeks ago that's uh that red
leg you made
yeah i can't take credit for that that's
um i make my own sauce
so every august get the uh
you know tomatoes i make the sauce i
jawed maybe about 120
25 mason jars but my girlfriend josefina
she's the one
she she's the cook she's she's really
good so i can't those meatballs look
[__] delicious
i gotta tell you she's great i go for
three of them right now
but dom i love you man i'm happy you
took the time
uh yeah we've become friends on social
media which is a positive
especially in these times and uh i'm a
big fan of your work
i loved you and a couple things that
you've done
uh when i saw you law and autumn like
this guy's a career actor
what the [__] he's not just a half a
wise guy from the bronx this guy
is the real deal so uh you have a big
fan with me
and anytime you want to come on likewise
i just wanted to get you on and talk
some [__]
and uh let people know we're not
we're moving we put our pants on one leg
at a time just like everybody else
that's it
i try to tell them so whatever you guys
are going through at home
we're going through so we're going
through it together so why be mad at
each other why turn on each other
let's uh spread love tell people you
love them
and that's all i can do dom and i'll be
uh calling you
now that now that's church
that's church that's church man well
said joey well said
i'll be calling you for directions on
that house or uh
yeah a company who does it you want to
come up and you want to get out of uh
just come up you know you you you know
how to get a hold of me so
absolutely it'd be great you're always
welcome here
man thank you i love you in all my heart
you have all my respect i love you too
thank you for taking the time
and coming on today and if you ever need
anything please feel free to reach out
brother
thank you joey love you brother have a
good day thank you
peace see you peace
all right you [__] i want to
thank dominic lombardosi great actor
great guy just loves comedy i love him
to that uh
i want to thank you guys and i want to
thank uh just you [__]
for being here for being loyal soldiers
whether it's here
on the uh joint or on patreon wherever
you're at
but listen from your balls to the butt
the best in men's grooming is manscaped
the holidays are almost here
and it's the number one most wanted gift
is manscape
you're gonna trim that [__] lug stick
and you're gonna [__]
trim you down your nut sack and manscape
to be the perfect gift
why because you got dads you got
brothers you got uncles
everybody's sitting on their [__]
asses for months growing roots and vines
it's time for them to clean out that
[__] [__] that dick bowl
and that nut sack give the gift of
manscape
get a smooth goblet without carving the
turkey if you know what i mean
with their skin safe technology that
won't
[__] destroy your nut sack get it all
in the performance package like joey
what's the [__] performance package
the performance package comes with the
weed whacker
a nose trimmer and with the the hair
trimmer
and nose trimmer they got 9000 rpm motor
i'll take anything out of that
and a blade that moves at 360 degrees
to clean out your nose pubes you also
get the lawnmower 3.0
the best known trimmer of mankind and
you get the crop preserver
the crop reviver to keep everything
smelling fresh
smooth plus they're throwing in a free
travel bag
with boxer shorts if you order right now
you can't beat that
naughty and nice manscaped is coming to
your chimney
listen guys this is the easy gift you
don't know what to get people
you're not going to be in malls this
year you're not going to have a chance
to walk around
just throw them a [__] manscape and
i'm giving you 20
off and free shipping right now today at
manscape.com
use code joey again that's 20 off with
free shipping
at manscape.com use code joey you get
this for your granddad
your father your [__] uncles who
gives a [__]
let them trim up their ball sack
disgusting animals that they are
go to manscape.com right now and preston
joey
i want to welcome to the to the joint
united harvest
what a [__] box what a [__]
surprise
how beautiful and this meat was how it
was packed
this is what i'm talking about there's a
lot of other companies that sell you
meat in a box
but it never looks like the [__]
pictures does it and it tastes like the
cardboard they sent on it
not with united harvest they sent me
pork bellies ribs briskets chops
sausages lamb
and a rib eye that made my wife cook
listen thursday night jimmy came over
that's the rib i asked jimmy florentine
how good it was
but they're not [__] around over
there united harvest they're a new
virtual farmer's market
and get this the best that american
ranchers have to offer
without leaving your house again
they might shut it down they might not
you don't know that but you want to be
[__] prepared
go to united harvest right now the lamb
chops are so tender they're falling off
the bone
the new york strip comes from cows that
eat potatoes
not [__] corn these cows eat better
than most of you [__] people do every
day
plus the way go beef it's tip top magoo
everything gets processed
in oregon by an expert butcher and scent
overnight
it's premium it's fresh and it's fast
high quality small batch meats
at surprisingly good price and support
small farms with
old school the right way here's what i
want you to do go to unitedharvest.com
that's unitedharvest.com and press code
joey to get 20
off the site with your order of 50 or
more
that's unitedharvest.com and use promo
code joey
stay out of the grocery store if you
want value
quality flavor and convenience check out
unitedharvest.com
and be sure to press promo code joey to
save 20
off your order of 50 or more
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
lion this
is it [__] my favorite from the
roll on to the cream
to the gummy bears whether it's tropical
raspberry orange
the bath balls i mean listen if they if
they make a product
cbd lion has it covered now they got
dark chocolate
and they have the milk chocolate listen
i've been doing business with them for
two years i use their products
i love that product cbd line is the way
to go
and they have a sale starting today over
at cbd live
so when you go over there read about cbd
learn about cbn but also get yourself
educated on what they have
at the end preston joey preston church
they're going to give you 20 off no
matter what the [__] you're pressing
because you tell them uncle joey sent
you all right so joey
church 20 off biggest sale of the year
black friday
starts today at cbd line i want to thank
cbd lyon
i want to thank united harvest and i
want to thank manscape for having our
back here at the joint
i want to thank you guys you're
traveling you're doing what you're doing
be safe and have a happy thanksgiving
[__]
see you wednesday
you